We'll begin with patient
access to their own data, and
we'll see how the bar gets raised as
the stages of meaningful use progress.
We've discussed the requirements
in the first two stages.
In Stage 3, as proposed,
80% of patients must be able
to access their records either
through the VDT function,
or through an ONC certified API, or
application programming interface.
And 35% must have access to
patient-specific educational materials.
We mentioned the term API in our
team project discussion near
the end of lesson one,
when we discussed FHIR.
For all practical purposes,
these two terms are probably going to be
synonymous in healthcare, that is FHIR
will be the API used in healthcare.
Unsurprisingly, Stage 3 also raises
the bar on actual patient engagement.
25% of patients must
access their records,
either through VDT or
through an ONC-certified API.
35% of patients must receive
a clinically relevant secure message.
And of great interest with respect
to patient phasing technologies
such as those we'll
discuss in lesson seven,
providers must incorporate
patient-generated data from non-clinical
settings such as home health for
15% of their patients.
This requirement clearly anticipates the
increased use of mobile technologies and
sensors in the home.
Stage 3's proposed provider
requirements also increase
the percentage of
e-prescriptions to 85% for
eligible providers and
25% for eligible hospitals.
They also require the use of 5 clinical
decision support tools tied
to 4 quality measures.
And providers must use drug to drug and
drug to allergy interaction alerts
during the entire reporting period.
Hospitals must receive at least
80% of medication orders,
60% of laboratory orders and
60% of diagnostic imaging
orders via computer-based
physician order entry.
Although order entry by scribes,
assistants to physicians who enter
the information for them,
does count toward these goals.
Finally, Stage 3 has specific
interoperability requirements.
Providers must send
an electronic summary for
50% of transitions of care and
referrals.
You recall that these are major
sources of error in patient care.
They must receive an electronic summary
for 40% of transitions and referral.
And providers must perform medication
allergy problem list reconciliation for
80% of transitions of care and
referrals.
Finally, eligible providers
must electronically submit
three out of five of the following
reporting requirements.
Immunizations, syndromic surveillance,
this would be for infectious diseases.
Reportable conditions case reporting,
certain conditions that need to
be reported to public health.
Public health registries to keep
track of certain diseases and
conditions and non public health
registries, such as those for cancer.
Eligible hospitals must submit
four from the same list
to which electronic lab
reporting is added.